hey yo i'm gonna fight the terminator
like the predator i will drop first
blood on you
interpret in the comments what we said
terminator versus
rambo immortal combat 11
round one let's do this
in the future machines are in charge all
human life is terminated
[Laughter]
wish fulfillment
[Music]
[Applause]
nice nicest
yes
[Music]
damn yeah the bow and arrow is cool but
it's not gonna do much to terminate
come on rambo you are obviously an
exoskeleton
[Applause]
over
oh
get over it here
and that's not even the face allen
oh
[Music]
you got this rambo oh
[Laughter]
dude ripping through that alloy
that was something special
that's better than a cup of coffee to
start your day it works on so many
levels
we wanted a stallone and schwarzenegger
movie for so long and then it's like you
get a little
bit of that and expendables you get
escape plan when no one really cared
anymore
this was the mash-up we wanted yeah
something like this is what we wanted
forever ago like the cinematic dream
crossover i feel like you can still do
it
why not do it who cares wage them bring
it to life
it doesn't matter don't even de-age them
you have arnold being old man terminator
you have old man of rambo just have them
go toe-to-toe they still know how to do
gun action scenes and stuff they're
still both really buff make it happen
honestly i really honestly hope they do
like the boundaries of what you can do
with these sequels and especially with
terminator sequels are getting very thin
this gave me a glimpse of yeah something
that's just so righteous and carnage
heavy
and again they did that thing i was
wondering when we started this i was
like
they're not going to let the terminator
win this even though it was rambo's like
character
yeah yeah rambo has to win but i like
that they like really kind of drew it
out so like even though it is just all
like video game demo
yeah at the same time there's a little
bit of that narrative arc there
for you know just like kind of having
fun with movie characters i appreciated
that i was playing mortal kombat 11 last
week with my buddy and
i suck at using the terminator like
watching this trailer
it's gonna go why why can't i do
anywhere near
the amount of moves that this trailer is
showing me i really suck at using it
because every time i use him i blame the
character and then i watch one of these
game trailers
i'm like no it's me there's something
i'm doing yeah i'm not doing it
i read the combo list i'm trying to do
everything i'm like why am i not pulling
off all the crazy stuff i haven't used
rambo yet but but you're gonna have to i
mean the second rambo came out
the the thing that we said was we got to
get some footage of terminator reversing
rambo and this is
all i wanted right here i don't have to
talk about any of the specifics because
it's
everything that i wanted all encompassed
in this one trailer this is everything
mortal kombat games are for now yeah
your insulin mortal kombat will just be
celebrity death match-up games and
that's all it's going to be all right
guys well rambo versus terminator
which one are you gonna play as when it
comes time to create the cinematic
crossover in this video game leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
notification bell
hit that like button catch you guys soon
you